quelle sera l'orthographe de l'an 2000
et bien on peut se poser la question
puisque si bien de bons esprits
justement à l'armée par certaines de ces
difficultés au parle même d'anomalie
sont sérieusement sinon à la réformée
tout au moins à la simplifier
sérieusement notre orthographe en effet
présent des anomalies des choses qui les
difficiles d'expliquer et je crois que
c'était la secrétaire pour personne ni
pour les enfants ni pour nous-mêmes
qu'elle est évidemment difficile de ces
anomalies monsieur Aristide Bellay
directeur général honoraires de
l'enseignement primaire et président de
la commission ministérielle des études
orthographiques va vous en montrer
quelques-unes
la langue française à la réputation
d'être une langue cohérente et logique
et évidemment c'est une des qualités de
la langue dans les Français sont le plus
fiers
lorsque je regarde ces mots que je viens
d'écrire au tableau
je me demande
si cette logique est une aussi
impeccable que les Français le croient
et le disent quelles raisons de donner
deux n à sonner et un seul à sonore deux
générationnels et un rationalisme etc
deux scènes à honneur et un oreille deux
œufs à siffler un nef à persifier et je
peux continuer je peux par exemple noter
que le féminin de saut
c'est ça
mais le féminin de Bigot
c'est bigote avec un seul t
on pourrait multiplier et ainsi des
exemples surprenants et qui ne sont pas
de nature à nous réjouir
si nous tenons à notre réputation de
bonnes logiques un autre un ou deux
autres exemples
la citronnade avec deux n provient des
citrons comme la limonade
revient du limon alors il y a deux zones
à citronnade un citronnade et un an à
limonade mais plus remarquable encore
ce que
ce qu'on critique
on dit que c'est
critical
mais ce qu'on applique
on assure que c'est
applicable et on pourrait multiplier
ainsi des exemples qui montreraient que
la logique française n'est pas aussi
parfaite qu'on le dit
[Musique]